hey a horror movie that up until about
three weeks ago there wasn't even a
trailer for we didn't know existed why
not it's the makings of a good horror
movie ring because if aliens taught us
anything if you want to make a sequel
just take the title of the original make
a plural oh so rings is a sequel to the
ring I don't even know if it's a sequel
to the ring - because I never saw the
ring - hasn't heard it was ball but in
the original ring there's this VHS tape
and then people watch it this is creepy
ass imagery then the phone rings when it
ends you pick it up and this little boy
says seven days you have seven days then
you're going to die on the seventh day
she's pretty much the premise of rings
except the file is digital now pretty
much the same thing and it focus was on
this girl whose boyfriend goes to
college and she stops hearing from him
and instead of filing a missing-persons
report or something she plays magnum p.i
and goes and investigates herself now
they have to solve the mystery of this
video and why it's all happening and
everything it you're like what they
solves that in the ring why are we here
well then new mysteries are there and I
gotta say this movie is actually not
complete [ __ ] that is the blu-ray quote
right there from me brain it's not
complete [ __ ] seriously something
echoing the first dude watches the video
I mean I'm not talking the plain scene
which is the worst marketing tactic ever
why would you release a clip of a movie
that is pretty much like reminds you of
final destination and is acted how
people would think rings would be acted
horrible don't do that but this
professor watches it she had some really
creepy ass imagery the rains going
upwards instead of downwards when he's
looking at his window I thought that was
rad I'm from right there I was like
maybe this movie might have Sun behind
it there's nothing about the jump scare
the jump scares in the movie there is
dumb as jump scares ever are and they
never got me because it was so obvious
like when a girl is looking through a
keyhole yeah something's going to jump
in front of it give a countdown three
two one and jump here yeah I know it
didn't get me that's not me bitching
about the fact that I didn't jump during
the jump scares that's me bitching about
the fact that jump scares are even in it
and why I have them but it's not really
about the jumpsuit it's not really about
people watching the video and dying the
movies actually do it score a mystery
they have to solve this mystery of why
this all happened and where it came from
what's making the entity do it there are
clues in the video and they have to
chase the breadcrumbs and solve it I
thought that was actually pretty neat so
many times I give horror movie [ __ ]
because it's like adds just a Gore fest
or it's a jump scare fest this movie
actually committed to the prospect and
idea
forming a mystery around the ghost
neither those really nice it doesn't
mean that execution is always great now
the movie is actually quite boring in
many things yeah you're gonna have a
mystery you have to have great acting a
great antagonist tone atmosphere which
this movie does have tone and atmosphere
in scenes it's not always it's a teenage
movie trying to play with your grown-up
friend leaves a little kids table the
milk and come over to the champagne it's
not quite there yet but the movie is a
bit too long for its own good I don't
even know if the movie is a full two
hours long it's probably an hour and a
half set it's like any rated pg-13
horror movie is I love I just didn't
always seem that way because movie
dragged on in many scenes of
uninteresting things happening in an
uninteresting ass town with
uninteresting as people and the end of
the movies stupid I just thought it was
dumb it didn't make any sense part of
the world they built up and built around
the whole thing and the reason things
were happening were because of X which
means the ending is just dumb it was
like that like a lino post-credits say
now is it sort of thing I know I'm
staying to the credits this thing it's
just put it at the end of the movie guys
in the end rings isn't complete [ __ ] nor
is it as bad as I thought it was going
to be but a phrase like that doesn't
actually tell you the quality of the
movie so I will say that rings has neat
visuals neat concepts in it I'm glad to
it scored there actually it's a mystery
movie they're trying to find out why
things are happening the way they are
but in the end the movie slows down to a
crawl the plot gets a little too
convoluted for its own good and still
has that pg-13 horror movie angst feel
to it and it Lily whose plot would have
been better reserved for the adults you
like a rated R movie that really wanted
to take it seriously in rings I enjoyed
every bit as much as I hated and in the
end I will say rings probably would have
been a better time if I were drunk and
now it's a party target audience getting
get drunk during this movie that's a
paradox that's true smut sucks alright
guys so rings have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]